oder was geht ab hier soll max und
herzlich willkommen zu diesem video wir
spielen heute speedway das zusammen mit
peter leute grüße ich bin ziemlich
verschnupft wir vielleicht hält speedway
das ist wie master builders nur dass es
darum geht nur an das komplett anders zu
sein
wir müssen einfach das was jetzt gleich
gezeigt wird für ein paar sekunden
okay das müssen wir nach bauen ort ist
schwierig mit den pilzen und zwar eins
zu eins so ist ein pilz das kann schon
mal merken wo gott oh gott ich glaube
ich war schon direkt verpacken gott ist
mit den mit den aktivitäten habe ich
nicht gecheckt alter ja richtig das war
so richtig tricky leute es ist ich finde
es irgendwie cooler als master will das
weiter muss man nicht so wirklich gut
für bauen müssen bauen können müssen
weil in diesen ganzen raum dazu bauen
alter alle einheit schon perfect match
hat sie einfach genau gemerkt wo die
pilze hinkommt na gut man kann natürlich
auch super typen dabei also man kann
sich einfach einen screenshot machen und
den also f5 sagte machst du den
screenshot geht auf jeden fall so klar
du kannst hier heftig bieten
ich glaube bei mir was ganz ok ich hab'
ich hab's spitze komplett falsch gesehen
ich habe glaube ich auch einen komplett
falsch gesetzt ach ja her habe ich aber
89 prozent ich bin raus
in der ersten runde schnell also ich hab
gar nicht mehr gesehen aber ich denke
mit werden sowieso
ok ok wo bist du ich sehe hier
zwei in der höhe ich glaube was lachte
ich schon was falsch als fehler
was mir angst eine art schon perfect
match alter nach zwölf sekunden ein
oh gott da könnte ich mich nicht aber
hochbahn wobei die zeit lang habe ich
trotzdem ihr hat tui sieht gysi das
dürfte auch ein perfect match gegen alle
haben einfach es ja auch crazies
irgendwie fall einfach ich glaube da
geht es jetzt einfach nur darum schnell
zu bauen war schon okay einer muss noch
drauf so komm komm komm ich glaube ja
schon verdammt
aber ich glaube selbst wenn alle hunde
sind wirklich alle gut ausgebucht du
bist mir erst mal rausgeflogen eines
ausflugs alter wahrscheinlich war er gut
im film public normalerweise werden dass
die grüne leute vor der tür weit bei dir
das ist schwierig 22 sind die
identischen das geht muss halt nur die
untere seite und das allen seiten
ok oh gott oh gott ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher werde falls es übrigens ein
bisschen lauter ist bei mir das leid
ein paar gäste wieder kein patch wird
weiter weil hier auch nicht nein du hast
was falsch sagen was ich kann ihnen aber
anstatt wenig schade dass man das dann
auch anschauen kann perfekt aber ich
hatte noch welche in der hand
dieser bleibt die große inflation hat
der hat empfehlen sieht mich viele
blöcke 68 doch verdammt
aber ich hatte einfach nur drei in der
hand noch drei blöcke ich glaube das ist
schlimmer als wenn man wenn man sie
irgendwie falsch
ok ja dann gingen wir in die zweite
runde ich bin gespannt ob täter dann
noch besser wird wir sind jetzt wieder
in der rolle und ich weiß nicht was wird
man als bauen müssen ich glaube es
schwierig 123 ich glaube gott ich glaube
ich alle schwierig
ich hab mich gut aufgepasst vor alter
etwas schwer etwa ohne wilsmann gott du
gibst ich wollte eigentlich eine ecke
angefangen haben aber nicht das war
schon richtig so muss man bei der glotze
leider hast ich habe dann abgerissen bis
zum durst löschen
wo gott keine ahnung was ich hier hapert
könnte richtig sein wenn freilich gott
ist es so kacke geworden ist wirklich in
der ersten raus geschickt
jetzt liege ich in der ersten raus es
wird so scheiße wenig ich habe einfach
nur 52 prozent warte ich ab 23
fussball lix von dir an die
unrealistisch ist
doch vor dem was jetzt kommt wieder
sowas einfach es heißt du ach komm
das spiel ist einfach nur korrupte
bargteheider etwas was meinst du
forderst du noch nur neue runde ein
die leute denken er ist übelste schmuck
aber das war jetzt andere von dem typ
linke war cewe color holding er hat
einfach nur auf einem layer geworden
also hat man auch er eine einzelnen
verdammten höher gebaut und welche
kriterien
deshalb ist es vielleicht ein bisschen
fähre leisten können leute noch darüber
entscheiden aber hier entscheidet
irgendwann bot den irgendwo robert j das
schlimmste ist wenn du die teil noch im
inventar hat das weibchen henkel hören
war da ich noch schlechter
ja ich dachte ich wollte mal so ein
bisschen so ein bisschen used look geben
verstehst du okay das hat das hat mir
einfach schon mal bei peter nádas hat es
ist eigentlich relativ easy zu machen
aber wie gesagt also da kann man es ist
echt noch was so cheating möglichkeiten
so was aus angeht ist es glaube ich ein
relativ und ausgereiftes system das
stimmt aber es kommt auf den also ich
denke man die machen was passiert du
kannst du irgendein kleines erstens in
fünf gruppen perfekt perfekt net/um
zweitens und zweitens weil ich es machen
und der bot lässt sich entscheidend auch
irgendwie ein bisschen betrügen sagt
wenn man halt irgendwie ein paar tricks
anwenden weil das zeigt schlechter aus
als peters hat das sind wahrscheinlich
einfach mehr blöcke in der richtigen
position aber es ist halt ähnlicher also
optisch ähnlicher vielleicht
aber wird dafür gegen blogger inventars
und schlechter gilt ich weiß es nicht
das ist ja wobei ich glaube es geht ok
konzentration gut fand ich wie macht man
den jetzt irgendwas mach ich falsch
schon wahrscheinlich drei einfach vorweg
match und als erster sogar jetzt habe
ich noch rausgeworfen hat vielleicht
gewinne ich diese runde über das vierte
die spiel aber irgendwie manchmal kann
es immer passieren dass du dich ein
bisschen verbrauchs und dann kommst du
zeitlich schon gar nicht mehr hin
von daher ist das relativ schwierig aber
gespannt wie die den den spielmodus
anpassen dass man nicht so bieten kann
oder ob es okay wobei eigentlich ist es
machbar da ich nur diese drei reihen
merken
aber das war ja bei mir eben auch in der
runde leute wenn ihr euch das mal
anschauen bei mir dann habe ich den
amboss einfach verloren hatte 0 einfach
so 0
ich frage mich wie kannst du 00 prozent
und er hat denn er hat ja was hier
gebaut weil nicht so als hätte ich 10
gebaut so 1 5 minuten
aber trotzdem es war schon ein bisschen
komisch dann perfekt meidlinger hab
glaub ich ein fehler in der höhe gemacht
oh gott oh gott ich habe falsche höhe
gebaut ich glaube der typ ist aber
schlecht als ich 16 72 und erhöhte er
den hätte ich gar nicht erwartet
aber das ist es das ist so das ding man
weiß es einfach nicht welche kriterien
123 gab so viele waren es gott oh gott
ist echt schwierig kriegs sn
ich hoffe für sie dass so viele die du
wieder platzieren muss und so muss halt
immer damit nicht selber hoch bauen es
auch tat
das schon schwer muss ich sagen in
diesen paar sekunden es geht gar nicht
vor allem glaube ich die anderen ländern
haben auch nicht bist du hast du hast
nicht das meiste die haben nämlich beim
boden angefangen die anderen
komm schon jetzt gucken so schnell bauen
bitte 750 habe ich nur damit so rolf
heuer
okay war einfach so dass das match als
stadtmensch 23 ich glaube ich glaube ich
hab's drin
das sind safe prozent ich glaube ich
hier am anfang die man hier kriegt ja
genau wenn du das einfach da war doch
wie war das denn die oberste er keine
ahnung hast noch holzbrücke über ja noch
dann muss noch welche was wir hatten
jetzt noch ich habe noch bis märz 79 79
ich hab das spiel gewann obwohl ich gar
nicht bauen kann
leute ihr könnt auch schaffen wenn ihr
lust habt dann geht auch mal auf mein
text überzeugt das scheint auch bei
peter vorbei da hatten wir eine sehr
lustige runde und ordern ist nichts was
gut tut